[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen oder mittag
oder abend oder keine ahnung was gerade
ist erwartet uns auf jeden fall hier in
unserer kleinen aktuell auch nicht allzu
süßen microsoft welt weil der liebe
freunde wir sind die in der letzten
episode i runtergegangen sind hier durch
die tür gegangen und dann hier im stream
heute in der festung angekommen und
haben dann auch direkt tatsächlich das
end portal hier vorne gefunden dort
werde ich auch heute noch nicht
reingehen das werde ich erst in folge
100 machen die vorbereitungen sind
allerdings getroffen wir haben das bett
hier hingestellt wir haben alles
ausgeleuchtet und ins bonner abgebaut
und heute meine lieben freunde werden
wir das frommhold ein bisschen weiter
erkunden ich nehme mal ganz kurz meine
fackeln packe die mal hierhin eine axt
brauchen wir denke ich nicht und wir
schauen uns ein bisschen weiter um wir
haben hier vorne noch einen raum wir
haben hier eine tür da vorne geht der
gang noch weiter und wer mir in der
letzten folge zum ende auch gesehen dass
man hier oben noch irgendwohin kann von
daher würde ich sagen gehen wir so
logisch vor und da wir von hier gekommen
sind würde ich sagen gehen wir als
erstes hier rechts herum und schauen was
sich hier hinter der tür befindet also
einfach mal direkt rein und wir sehen
dass ich leider höre und
zombies
ziemlich nahe
na gut ich werde einfach mal meine
bruchsteine nehmen und hier alles ein
bisschen schöner machen ich weiß dass
wir hier erst einmal jetzt zum ersten
mal gerade sind beziehungsweise waren
und wir werden ja auch nur ein einziges
weiteres mal hingehen das ist nämlich
bei folge 100
allerdings möchte ich halt dass wir hier
neben swo runterfallen oder irgendwelche
bösen bekanntschaft machen und daher bei
euch auch hier eine kleine absperrung
einfach mal dran und mache alles ein
bisschen entspannter dass wir hier gut
verlaufen können hier unten geht es auf
jeden fall weiter da schauen wir jetzt
einfach mal was uns hier erwartet ich
höre so viele monster hier vorne haben
wir die bibliothek da können wir gleich
auch auf jeden fall mal vorbeischauen
ich werde auch erst mal hier vorne
gucken dass ich ja alles so ein bisschen
aus leuchte dass hier nichts irgendwie
passiert da oben ist der kripo der
betreuer wächst ihr
warum springt er denn halb in sein tod
hier rein
was sollen dass
ich heute ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
und noch ein anderer mensch
hier geht es ordentlich ab ich werde den
händlern nicht angucken ich will sie
nicht mit ihm aufnehmen weil wir haben
genug ändert er nicht benötigen jetzt
nicht von daher werde ich ihn nicht
angreifen wir schauen uns allerdings
trotz immer weiter um wir haben hier
lava wasser
wie kann es denn sein dass wir hier
immer auf so viele monster treffen das
ist doch wirklich nicht mehr normal in
unserer welt ich hoffe einfach wirklich
dass es in staffel 2 von minecraft mit
luca nicht auch so ablaufen wird
allerdings sind wir hier auch schon am
ende von der schlucht angekommen klar
ich kann jetzt nicht jeden vorsprung
hier irgendwie ausleuchten was ich
allerdings mal machen kann ist hier
vorne das wasser so ein bisschen
einbauen dass wir hier nicht alles
überspült haben wir haben hier vorne
allerdings auch noch mal wasser was ihr
runter kommt das werde ich jetzt
allerdings auch noch mal eben kurz
einbauen dass wir auch hier keine bösen
überraschungen erleben werden den
endermann habe ich ja vorhin schon
gesagt lass dich am leben kohle und
eisen benötige ich erst mal nicht und
wir laufen zurück zum stronghold meine
lieben freunde wie kam ja vorhin von
hier vorne deswegen würde ich auch sagen
gehen wir in die richtung weiter runter
ich brauch dass sie jetzt einfach mal zu
so dass wir wissen und vor allem uns
auch sicher sein können dass hier
niemand mehr durchkommt und jetzt dem
wir hier unten mal rein ich weiß nicht
was uns erwartet ich weiß nicht ob hier
vielleicht sogar irgendwelche anderen
mops noch auf uns warten die ich gar
nicht mehr so richtig auf dem schirm
habe allerdings glaube ich dass dem
nicht der fall sein wird hier ist auch
alles schon so ein bisschen
ausgeleuchtet jeder allerdings immer
gerne auf nummer sicher wir laufen hier
vorne lang wir haben hier verliese
glaube sogar dass in solchen verliesen
manchmal truhen zu finden sind schauen
wir einfach mal rein wir haben hier
allerdings nichts leuchten trotzdem
natürlich alles aus und gehen jetzt mal
hier vorne durch weiter und entdecken
hier direkt die bibliothek ihr auch
schon vorne gekennzeichnet war
[Musik]
sie sind auch wieder in irgend einer
riesigen höhle hier drin ich weiß nicht
warum mein stronghold jetzt in meiner
welt direkt in so einem riesigen
höhlensystem hier am start ist
allerdings gibt es natürlich auch
schlimmere sachen vielleicht entdecken
wir hier irgendwie noch andere ärzte
oder finden diamanten oder so ich werde
jetzt allerdings auf jeden fall erstmal
eine menge bücherregale mitnehmen weil
wir die natürlich auch traden können mit
unseren village an auf unserer insel und
man bücher natürlich generell auch immer
ganz gut zum verzaubern nutzen kann ich
weiß nicht wie viel ich jetzt habe ich
habe 26 das sollte auf jeden fall
ausreichend beziehungsweise kann ich
auch mal so richtig gestein ziegel die
wegschmeißt an dem ich noch mal ein
bisschen mehr mit bücher sind auf jeden
fall wertvoller als irgendwelche blöcke
die wir hier die ganze zeit abbauen
[Musik]
kann ich diese truhe einfach aufmachen
ohne dass irgendwas aktiviert wird
dass das irgend eine falle ist oder so
ich probier's einfach mal und wir haben
durch schutz vier stärke 4 und
unendlichkeit und wir haben mehrfach
schutz lasst die schneebälle einfach mal
hier und nehme dieses buch mit und ich
lasse auch das verrottete fleisch und
nehme dieses buch hier mit ich könnte
natürlich jetzt sorgt weil ich einfach
mal eine kiste
nehmen und die einfach zu meinem start
mit dem kasachen
[Musik]
ich wusste gleich dass man diese blöcke
wo silberfische
drin sind mit einem schlag einfach
kaputt machen kann
[Musik]
aber gut freunde wir schauen uns auf
jeden fall die bibliothek immer weiter
an ich habe auf jeden fall genügend
bücher am start den helmen das war noch
ein verzauberter goldhelm den habe ich
da jetzt gerade einfach mal
hingeschmissen wenn ich ein bisschen
platz hatte hier haben wir halt überall
spinnenweben ich will die nicht mit
einem diamant schwert abbauen weil das
dadurch natürlich an haltbarkeit
verliert allerdings möchte ich mich ja
auch einfach generell noch mal ganz kurz
umschauen und gucken ob wir vielleicht
hier irgendwo noch kisten haben dem ist
allerdings nicht der fall wir haben noch
eine tür hier geht's weiter das ist
allerdings der weg den wir glaube ich
von oben auch hätten runter gehen können
genau hier unten geht es glaube ich
nicht mehr weiter ich kann noch mal ganz
kurz sie eben gucken hier vorne geht es
nicht mehr lange ich glaube ja genau
hier ist alles zu und hier kommen wir
nur wieder in die bibliothek rhein wo
also haben wir diesen
abschnitt dann tatsächlich auch schon zu
ende erkundet und klar geht es da vorne
noch in die höhle weiter und hier oben
auch allerdings wollen wir das ja heute
gar nicht machen hier vorne waren die
verliese wir gehen hier durch wieder
raus und können dementsprechend schon
mal sagen dass wir von hier kamen
natürlich und in die richtung auf jeden
fall nichts mehr als er geht hier vorne
ist nur lava ok krass aber auch gut zu
wissen und dann können wir uns jetzt ja
auch noch mal in der bibliothek hier
vorne umschauen dafür werde ich jetzt
erstmal ganz kurze machen dass ich meine
stein ziegel nehme und wir uns hier so
einen kleinen weg langen bauen und mit
viel glück finden wir darin natürlich
auch noch mal eine kiste wird auch noch
mal vielleicht irgendwie verzauberten
büchern verzauberten gegenständen
vielleicht auch schon direkt neben jetzt
einfach mal kurz ein diamant schwert
hierfür die ganzen fäden die haben
auch hier eine kiste
normale bücher und einfach nur papier
aber gut vielleicht haben wir irgendwo
noch eine zweite kiste in jeder bücherei
haben wir auch einen kleinen weg nach
oben bzw eine lite gerade zwei macs hier
[Musik]
und doch hoch
runter
in jeder bücherei wollte ich gerade
sagen haben wir natürlich auch eine
leiter nach oben und das jetzt natürlich
nur der untere abschnitt ich weiß nicht
wo diese leiter ist nach oben geht
allerdings geht die ja immer irgendwo am
rand hier langsamer von schon
reingeguckt hier geht es auch noch lange
keine ahnung wo es langgeht ich glaube
allerdings perfekt okay wir kommen hier
aus dem gang raus indem ihr vorhin auch
noch eingehen wollten hier vorne das
führt uns nicht das wird einfach nur
runter dann ist nämlich alles doch
verboten und das ronald ist doch nicht
so riesig wie ich dachte allerdings
möchte ich noch einmal oben in die
bibliothek reingehen ich weiß nicht wie
wir hier hoch kommen sie ist nirgends
wurde leiter jetzt hätte ich auch noch
ein faden drin und daher muss ich mich
glaube ich einfach hoch bauen
[Musik]
geht's noch lang oder war das hier die
bibliothek in die wir gerade rein
gegangen sind ich weiß es nicht die
sicht auf jeden fall ein bisschen anders
aus aniko ja mehr die ganzen sachen
abbaut die kiste damit öffnet die frage
ist nur ob sich hier unten auch noch
eine kiste befindet weil die kiste die
wir gerade gesehen haben
ich habe ich von da nicht gesehen
dies mir gar nicht aufgefallen als ich
durchgelaufen bin
da vorne ist
flamme harpune und schutz 4 er verlasse
ich das eisen einfach mal hier drin und
schärfe 3 und schutz 3 dafür lasse ich
einfach mal den gold beiden schutz mit
der mit dem feuerschutz zauber drauf
hier drin wir haben auf jeden fall
krasse verzauberungen hier am start die
wir hier entdecken das ist sehr sehr
sehr sehr geile können wir auch mal gern
und in die kommentare schreiben auf was
ich jetzt was genau drauf verzaubern
soll allerdings schauen wir jetzt
einfach mal im oberen stockwerk und
dieser bibliothek ob wir da eventuell
auch noch was finden werden dafür baue
ich mich jetzt einfach mal hier zwischen
hoch und werde jetzt einfach mal schauen
ob wir hier vielleicht auch noch eine
kiste hätten das wäre natürlich der
absolute kracher
es tut mir leid dass ich gerade rede wie
so ein 50-jähriger mit solchen wörtern
aber wir haben auch hier dornen zwei
behutsamkeit haben wir auch hier drin
dafür lasse ich jetzt einfach mal
er brauche ich nicht davon habe ich
schon eine und wir haben schärfere
explosionsschutz 4 was auch für das ende
von extrem wichtiger bedeutung ist dem
zaun das jetzt einfach mal ab hier drin
ich glaube mehr sachen haben wir hier
nicht ich kann mir noch ein paar bücher
holen ich habe mich 47 stück und da kann
man das ganze dreck auf jeden fall noch
kurzem voll machen derzeit 36 bücher ich
glaube mehr benötigen wir wirklich nicht
und schlussendlich haben wir auch damit
dass stronghold glaube ich zu ende
entdeckt wir vorne geht es nur runter in
die zweite etage da gehe ich mal ganz
kurz hier über meinen weg lieber unter
damit ich mir keinen fall schaden noch
irgendwie nehme so perfekt kläger hat
überhaupt nicht geklappt und jetzt
können wir auch einfach durch unseren
weg durch den wir hier vorne auch
reingekommen sind einfach wieder
rausgehen das war ja hier vorne zack und
dann schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz und
vergleichen das mit dem beginn der
heutigen folge ob wir alle räume jetzt
heute entdeckt haben hier vorne sind wir
rein gekommen dann habe ich hier diesen
weg lang gebaut und dieses geländer das
war ja noch in der letzten episode
und dann sind wir vorne durchgegangen
und waren hier
und sind quasi hier dann darf zum portal
gekommen haben dann hier fordere die
wege entdeckt hier vorne sind wir lange
laufen da unten links haben diese
bibliothek entdeckt wir sind den weg
gelaufen wir sind hier lange laufen wo
es nichts gab und hier das war einfach
nur ein rundkurs um wieder zur
bibliothek zu bekommen wir waren
allerdings noch nicht hier oben fällt
mir gerade auf das heißt hier müssen wir
auf jeden fall noch mal ganz gut gehen
hier seine kiste und mehr ist hier nicht
wie kommt man auch nicht noch irgendwo
lang ich werde gleich auf jeden fall
noch mal ganz kurz mich dort vorne lang
bewegen und schauen ob da noch was ist
allerdings guck mir dass meine kiste und
sehen nur kohle wie wir allerdings auch
selbstverständlich mitnehmen und einen
apfel den brauchen wir nicht
beziehungsweise kann ich den ganz kurz
nehmen und mal eben kurz essen so das
wird zumindest ein bisschen unser leben
wieder auffüllen allerdings kann ich
dann auch wieder hier diese
ofenkartoffeln reinhauen jetzt werde ich
zum ende der heutigen piloten
ich kann gar nicht mehr reden will auf
jeden fall noch einmal kurze vorne
gucken ob ihr noch irgendwas ist
allerdings ist das nur hier der
ausläufer von der bibliothek von daher
meine lieben freunde würde ich sagen
haben wir die festung zu ende entdeckt
wir wissen ganz genau dass sich wenn wir
reingehen hier vorne dass ein portal
befindet und das hier ist er der weg
nach drinnen wir haben hier zwar noch
eine höhle allerdings ist der schalter
weg
eisenführ einfach mal ab die brauche ich
nicht die stelle immerhin wir wissen auf
jeden fall wie wir zum and poor tal
kommen und wir wissen auch wie wir nach
draußen kommen da müssen wir nämlich
ganz easy einfach entspannt hier
durchlaufen sehen dann hier unseren weg
und wissen auch dass wir hier wieder
nach oben laufen können es ist glaube
ich tat es sieht nur so dunkel aus weil
ich da oben ja die hütte für balu gebaut
habe allerdings
haben wir es wirklich fertig entdeckt
wir haben die festung erobert wir haben
die monster getötet und es ist nacht
[Musik]
und ich höre menge monster
von daher werde ich zu machen meine
lieben freunde dass ich zurück laufen
werde zum end portal und ich werde mich
dort jetzt auch mal ganz kurz schlafen
legen sodass wir auf jeden fall dort
schon mal den zorn gesetzt haben ich
weiß wir werden den spot wahrscheinlich
auch noch mal anders setzen weil ich
natürlich früher oder später auch ja
wieder zum dings laufen muss wieder bei
mir in ein bett gehen muss und
dementsprechend
ich weiß nicht wo lang
[Musik]
wenig dumm
magazin ok hier war es auf jeden fall
was ich will auf jeden fall sagen wollte
war das sich auf jeden fall noch einmal
in meiner welt schlafengehen werde also
auf meiner insel von daher werde ich
jetzt bauen ähnlich gelassen können
allerdings war ganz kurz die nacht zu
überspringen und dann dass wir zum ende
der heutigen episode auch nochmal ganz
fix nach oben gehen können so dass wir
halt wissen das auch wirklich tag ist
und dass wir mit balu dann in der
nächsten folge direkt wieder nach hause
laufen können uns anderen themen noch
mal ganz kurz zu beginn des projekts
widmen können von daher meine lieben
freunde schreibt ihr mir gern jetzt und
in die kommentare was ich in der
nächsten episode minecraft mit luca
machen soll und bin auch euro auch auf
eure hilfe angewiesen denn schreibt mir
auch gern bitte unter die kommentare was
ich mit diesem verzauberten büchern
jetzt machen soll worauf soll ich das
verzaubern nicht dass ich dann irgendwie
was auf meine schuhe pack und dann sagen
alle das gehört sich nicht auf die
schuhe das musst du bitte auf dein
schwert machen oder auch keine ahnung
was wir haben auf jeden fall eine menge
verzauberte bücher hier heute bekommen
also helft mir gern weiter ich bin ein
angebot auf eure hilfe balu ist auf
jeden fall noch hier am start der das
ganze überlebt von daher werde ich jetzt
auch mal ganz kurz die hundehütte wieder
abbauen und an der stelle meine lieben
freunde bleibt nur noch zu sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann das gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn die neue videos nicht
verpassen wollte mir hat sehr sehr viel
spaß gemacht heute ich liebe diese höhen
expedition zu folgen das war ein sehr
geiles ode wie ich also wir sehen uns in
der nächsten episode minecraft mit luca
wieder und balu
was sagen dass die letzten vier wörter
vier wörter
ehre mich mal machen
[Musik]